look just shut me I didn't mean to
that's nolan gould playing Luke Dunphy
in the modern family pilot nearly 10
years ago plastic babies it was an
accident
now no one is 20 and he's all grown up
on the cover of say prune magazine
inside the actor goes shirtless showing
off his abs I don't know if there's a
cut off but I'm 20 am I like am i told
Hollywood man the actor flexing his
muscles in this white tee and giving off
major Shawn Mendes vibes I really want
to get a photo with them just to dispel
any rumors I am Shawn Mendes do you hear
that all the time every day of my life
I'm not every single day of my life I'm
sure he does too so we like we'd like to
spell those rumors we're not the same
person although we've never been seen in
the same place at the same time are you
a Shawn fan maybe there's no I mean that
that Nolan smolders in this striped suit
it's hard to believe how much he's grown
up now he's heading into the final
season of Modern Family how would you
like to see a historian I'd like to see
to see him do something with his life
like he's going to Community College
right now I don't know I think it'd be
nice to see him like make something of
himself one way or another whether that
means like he becomes a refrigerator
repair like but I just wanna like see
some kind of like we have an idea of
what he's gonna do after Modern Family
but he's ready to say goodbye are you
looking forward though to sort of doing
something different out of the box away
from the show I mean there's definitely
you know part of it where you've been on
for 10 years so doing another season ah
it is a lot especially because I started
when I was 10 like I've got license I
want to go maybe think about college all
kinds of things
you